RACHEL: I am really pleased
and excited to have Judith
here today at Google
for our talk.
Dr. Judith Wright is hailed as
a peerless educator, world
class coach, lifestyles expert,
inspirational speaker,
best selling author, and
corporate consultant.
She's called one of America's
ultimate experts by "Women's
World Magazine." And Judith
has appeared in
over 500 radio stations--
I didn't even know there was
500 radio stations--
and 80 television shows.
Well, maybe there's 80
television shows--
including ABC's "20/20,"
"Oprah," "The Today Show," and
"Good Morning America."
Dr. Wright is the co-founder
of the Foundation for
Transformational Leadership, the
Wright Graduate Institute
offering master and doctoral
degrees and certificates in
transformational leadership
and coaching.
She also founded SOFIA,
the Society of
Femininity and Action.
So today we're really excited
because Dr. Wright is going to
share with us her cutting edge
research in the science behind
creating a spectacular life
and how to get rid of the
mindless habits that get in the
way of our mindfulness and
living a richer, fuller life.
So please welcome Dr.
Judith Wright.
JUDITH WRIGHT: Thank you.
Thanks, Rachel.
Thanks.
Thanks to all of you.
Thanks for having me and that
we're going to have this kind
of mindful mindlessness.
We're going to be more mindful
about our mindlessness.
And how many of you can admit
that perhaps you've had a
mindless moment somewhere
in your life?
Could I see there?
I want to check.
How many of you are so out
of it right now you
can't raise your hand?
I just want to see how we
want to play with that.
How many of you could
have been doing
something else right now?
Obviously, you could.
And you chose to be here.
I also want to find out,
do you participate?
Can we do this together?
All right, great.
Three of you said, uh huh.
So we're, OK.
We'll play with that.
Great.
What I'm going to be
working with--
I want to find out what
do you yearn for.
That's going to be a bigger term
that we're going to be
working with and how this
relates to mindfulness and
overcoming our mindless
habits.
But I'm going to ask you some
questions and if it feels like
something that matters to you
or that you yearn for, if
you'd raise your hand.
How many of you would really
like even more consciousness,
more mindfulness?
Can I see that?
OK, great.
How about some just real
basic stuff of life.
How about more time?
Who would like more time?
All right, great.
Perfect.
How about more money?
Let's just go at it that way.
But the rest of you
have too much?
We can trade a little.
We can mix it up a little bit.
How about more energy?
Can I see that?
How many of you don't
have energy to raise
your hand right now?
All right.
These are all related to what
we're going to talk about.
How about--
I think this means something--
meaning, fulfillment,
satisfaction, having your days
be more meaningful than
they might be now?
All right, good.
How about more satisfying
relationships, more intimacy?
Who's interested in that?
The rest of you just had
a bad relationship?
Are we like--
all right, great, just
want to check.
How about dealing with
stress better?
Who'd like that?
All right, good.
this helps me.
How about, who'd like
a better memory?
Who can't remember what
I just asked you?
This is related.
Then also how about learning
faster, remembering things
more, having more critical
thinking, having your
cognition be even better
than it is now.
All right, good.
How many of you are interested
in a deeper spiritual
relationship or spirituality?
OK.
How many of you would like
to maximize your IQ?
All right, good.
And this one's kind of generic,
but how many of you
would like an even
richer, deeper,
fuller quality of life?
OK.
And how about just
more happiness?
Can we see that?
All right.
I know these are related but
there's a specific reason I'm
mentioning all these different
things I'm talking about.
How about--
I think this is something that
many of us yearn for--
to realize our potential, become
who we could become,
live this life really,
really well.
Who's interested in that?
All right, great.
We talk about that as
the life project.
We go about our work projects
and our home projects, but
taking on our life project.
So how many of you would like a
well-lived life project that
gets a really good grade
or however it works
when you turn it in?
All right, good.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JUDITH WRIGHT: So all these
things I just mentioned,
they're very common
kinds of things.
But they're all very related
to what we're
talking about today.
And the research shows that
these are the things that are
impacted by the kinds of things
we're going to be
talking about today.
And the more we get more skill
with this, the more all those
results happen in our life.
And the less skill
we have, all of
those things are impacted.
That's how important it is
what we're talking about.
And obviously you're here
because you want something.
And we're going to learn
to grow together.
So part of where I'm going to
be coming from, I've been
spending 35 years of studying
great lives.
I grew up in a factory town.
So it was an interesting kind
of thing to see how people
chose to live their life.
So I was really interested in
who lives a better life.
Who lives a great life?
Who fulfills their potential?
How do you do this?
What is that?
So I've been studying
it for a long time.
It was part of my research.
It was part of my doctoral
dissertation.
And I really wanted to know
who really maximizes their
potential, what did they do
differently, what is that?
And it's led me on this kind
of amazing journey over all
this time, not just doing
research, but developing
curriculum, testing things out
with thousands and thousands
of people, developing ways to
help people learn life skills
to be able to get the best out
of their careers, their
personal lives, their
spirituality, their
relationships, their
family life.
And overall this time there's
some things that started to
become very clear to me, plus
looking at my own life as I
was on this journey.
And what I found is that
consciousness and
mindfulness--
and social, emotional
intelligence is obviously part
of this, as I'm sure many of
you know and have been
working with that.
But what I've been finding is
that there were some surprises
for me because what I thought
was a formula for a great life
is not exactly what the
research showed.
And that's what we're going to
be looking at today in how it
relates to our mindfulness
and how our mindlessness
subtracts from that.
So how many of you
are meditatators?
Can I see that?
All right, great.
How many of you consider
yourself on a spiritual path
of some sort?
How about just professional
development, learning, growing?
Personal development?
OK, great.
All of the above?
There's a few of us, OK.
All those things that you're
doing are really critical and
very important in terms
of quality of life and
productivity and all those
results we talked about.
However, these soft addictions,
mindlessness,
these places where we
go a bit unconscious
really take away from--
it's counterproductive to some
of our mindful practices.
So we want to work with that.
And also what we're looking at
and what our research shows is
how to be more mindful
moment to moment.
Day to day interactions with
every work project we're doing
with the people we're working
with, how do we bring a degree
of all of this thing that
matters to us in every single
moment of every day, rather than
having kind of a driven
life with a moment
of meditation?
How many of you can relate to
that, kind of like you're
sneaking it in sometimes?
All right, we want to work on
how to have that be more
available to you all the time.
So the big issue here is this
term that I coined over 20
years ago, soft addictions.
And they are where
we go mindless.
Every single one
of us does it.
In fact, a recent poll, 91%
percent of Americans admitted
to having soft addictions.
I think the other 9% are in
denial because I don't know
anybody who doesn't have moments
of mindlessness.
M
And you'll find just during
the time we're talking--
so how many of you have already
checked out several
times while we're talking?
You're checking your smartphone,
whatever--
yeah.
I'm not saying it has to be a
soft addiction but we go back
and forth this way.
I must say-- just say this,
full disclosure.
I'm not anti-technology.
I love technology.
It's a relationship
with it that we're
talking about today.
So soft addictions are those
seemingly harmless habits like
overeating, over shopping,
watching too much TV, checking
your Facebook pages a zillion
times during the day, checking
your email compulsively.
But over doing anything, over
doing any normal everyday
activity beyond its usefulness
for some other purposes.
And it has a lot more cost
than we're aware of.
It takes time, obviously.
It oftentimes cost money.
But it mutes our
consciousness.
That goes to anti-mindfulness.
It numbs ours feelings.
It reduces our social emotional
intelligence.
And it robs us of a lot of
energy and motivation.
So we're going to work with
this a little bit and then
look underneath the neuroscience
of that and how
human beings are so predisposed
to these kinds of
habits and what we
can do about it.
But rather than my talking about
them, we're going to
show a little video
clip from some
interviews that I've done.
But see if you can recognize
yourself.
And also watch if you're saying,
oh, I'm not that bad
because that's a clue too.
So let's look at this
for a second.
They're just lists of things.
It doesn't mean these things
are a problem.
But are you over doing
them sometimes?
Do you get kind of high or
buzzed or forgetful or kind of
numb when you're doing it?
Do people tease you about it?
Have you thought, oh, I'm
kind of over doing that?
Those kinds of things let us
know that these things might
be a little bit of an issue.
So I'm going to go
through these
categories really quickly.
Then I'm going to have you go
through the checklist and see
what you think might be
susceptible things for you so
we can have not just--
be more engaging.
If you need any of the hand
outs, just raise your hand.
We'll make sure you get those.
OK, great.
We'll pass a few more out.
So there's four categories of
soft addictions as I've been
studying this.
There's activities, the things
that you do too much of.
Can you shout some things out?
Not you, but your friends or
other people in the world.
What do they do?
What are some of the
things we overdo?
AUDIENCE: Email.
JUDITH WRIGHT: Email.
What else?
AUDIENCE: TV.
JUDITH WRIGHT: She's on
hers right now as
she's saying that.
TV.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JUDITH WRIGHT: She's
thinking no.
So all kinds of things.
It can be anything
that we overdo.
So activities--
they can be media.
They can be engaging activities,
things that we do.
So activities can become
a soft addiction.
There's another category,
which is interesting.
It's not doing activities,
procrastinating.
How many of you are guilty
of procrastinating?
And you know how we best
procrastinate?
We use other soft addictions
to do that.
We disappear for a
while to do this.
So procrastinate, not doing the
things we wish we had done
or not getting around to things,
that kind of thing.
There's a third category.
That's moods and
ways of being.
This one was interesting to me
because you can get kind of
addicted to ways of being.
How many of you know really
perpetually cranky people?
And it's like a habit.
It's like it's a reflex.
Or habitually smiley Pollyanna
types you sometimes run into.
Or sarcastic, not like there
has to be wrong but there's
like a reflexive, anytime
something gets uncomfortable,
somebody responds with this kind
of mood or way of being.
And now they're finding that
the neurochemical wash that
goes on with these moods that
we get addicted to, as those
moods come up, and if we're not
feeling that, we think a
thought that triggers that same
neurochemical wash that
brings that mood back.
It's fascinating.
So moods and ways of being can
be also soft addictions.
And things related to activities
are just things,
consumable, edible
kinds of things.
And it can be your favorite
chocolate or
collections that you have.
I was doing a talk and a woman
said, oh, I think I have a
thing addiction.
I said, well, most of us do.
What is that?
She says, well, it's a food.
It's a food group.
And I said, what is that?
She says, it's the
eeto food group.
And I was like, what is that?
I thought it was like Asian
fusion or something.
She said, no, Cheetos,
Frito, Doritos.
I said, oh, yeah I got it.
Now, I understand.
So maybe that's something
of yours as well.
So take just a moment or two
and take that checklist.
Mark anything you think you
might be susceptible to so
that we're all in here
as human beings
working on this together.
Oh, yeah.
There should be blanks on
there because anything
overdone can-- even
great stuff.
Playing chess can become
a soft addiction.
One woman told me she
volunteered too much.
And she really did.
She was volunteering every day
and wasn't getting on with
sending her resume out, getting
a new job, things she
needed to do.
So even practicing an instrument
can become a soft
addiction if you're over using
it to avoid some other kinds
of activities.
So add anything that you might
be susceptible to.
Well let me find out.
How many of you had more in the
activities column, more
stuff you over do?
Let me see that.
OK.
How many of you more in the
avoidances, things you don't
do, the procrastination or not
getting around to things?
How about the mood addictions?
Anybody find those for yourself,
mood or way of being
addictions?
How about just plain old stuff,
whether it's chocolate
or collections or whatever
in that way?
OK, great.
The rest of you don't have soft
addictions or are you
still working on it?
Because I just want you to see--
and I'm not saying these
necessarily are.
It's our relationship
with these things.
And partly I really want
us to look at it.
We're going to understand the
addictive nature of human
beings and what to do to unlock
this so that all of the
practices that we're doing are
mindful practices, our yoga
that we do, our thoughtfulness,
our critical
thinking, all the capacities we
have are maximized rather
than compromised.
So that's why I want you
to be looking at that.
I can tell you some of mine.
And I've been working
with them.
But for me it was nail
biting and catalogs.
I would just disappear.
I would open a catalog and it
was like I was in a dreamland
for a period of time where it's
just like lots of time
would go by.
And I'm a reader.
And a lot of times I'm reading
for stimulation, intellectual
development, all kinds of
things, or research.
But there's a lot of times I'm
reading it like it's just to
disappear and just go mindless
for a period of time,
depending on the reading
material that I have.
So if I can tell you mine,
you can tell me yours.
So anybody willing to share and
just shout a few things
out you might have
a soft addiction?
AUDIENCE: Diet soda.
JUDITH WRIGHT: Diet soda.
Oh, that's a really
popular one.
That's great.
Great, thanks.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Wikipedia.
JUDITH WRIGHT: Wikipedia.
That's great.
What else?
How many of you have food
addictions like chocolate or
salty, crunchy things
or whatever?
I know.
So that's a very common
one as well.
So I just want you in the game
with this because if you've
got one or two you're thinking
about, you're going to
personalize what we're talking
about a little bit more and
see what this is.
This isn't about-- and we're
going to find out the wisdom
that our soft addictions have.
There's beautiful messages and
there's really interesting
information in them.
So we're going to learn to
translate those by the end of
the talk today to find
out what are they
trying to tell us.
Why are we doing that?
What's trying to get
our attention?
And what's the neuroscience
underneath it that we can pay
attention to it and shift it?
But lest you think this is just
a phenomenon of modern
times, it's not.
Because many people tell
me that, oh, it's just
technology.
That's why I'm so addicted.
No.
The ancient Greeks were dealing
with something very,
very similar where they were
talking about that.
The Greek word is akrasia.
And I think it makes
you crazia.
Because akrasia, it's doing
things that you know just
aren't that great for you,
whether it's loss of self
control or over indulging in
things that aren't that great,
but doing things that you don't
feel that great about or
you know aren't so
positive for you.
And it's interesting because
they called it acting against
your better judgment.
How many of you ever acted
against your better judgment
and then justified
it afterwards?
That's part of it too.
That's how you know you're in
that kind of territory.
So it's really interesting.
So it's fascinating because
they're the same categories,
over doing activities, like I
have, and then under doing
them, avoiding things, like
procrastination or putting
things off, that
kind of thing.
They looked at those two
categories as well.
But then they're talking about
this addictive stuff.
And I'm using that word for
a reason because addiction
actually means in Latin--
it's turning yourself over.
It's giving yourself
over to something.
We're not always that
considerate about what we're
turning ourselves over to.
And addiction means the
repetitive behaviors that
we're doing and doing things
that we know aren't good for
us, that are actually bad for
us, but still have the
desire to do it.
Who here, besides me, can admit
you've had the desire to
do some things that aren't
all that great for you?
And how many of you have
acted on that desire?
Me as well.
That's part of what
all this is about.
So one of the biggest things
that gets in the way, that's
related to this akrasia is we
have this fundamental issue
about how we weight
consequences.
Now, I think you can relate
to this because when we
overweight immediate
consequences and don't think
about long term-- and it's so
hard in the moment because
what seems really like right
now consequences, like the
comfiness of this couch, that
wonderful taste of that
chocolate cake, that laughter
of that talking kitty video.
You know, those things seem like
the most important thing
in the moment when you're
stuck by those.
But other consequences
are more distant.
It's like your long term career
goals or losing weight
or shifting something in
your life over time.
And we have this immediate
and long term.
We tend to weight
the immediate--
and this is evolutionary, we'll
find out in a moment.
We tend to weight the immediate
much heavier than
the long term, which is why we
don't often get everything we
could out of life.
And it's really interesting.
And they call it time
inconsistency or dynamic
inconsistency.
But see if you can
relate to this.
Here's what this study shows,
the research shows.
If you're ordering food for next
week, if you're ordering
some groceries for next week,
you put together a really
great shopping list.
It's got fruits and vegetables
and lean meats.
It's really healthy.
It's wonderful.
However, if you go shopping
tonight, guess what you buy?
Pizza, chips, ice cream.
And the studies show this.
But think about it.
It's a little different
now when you're
streaming movies and stuff.
But remember when you would
get your Netflix or other
things, and you'd get things
waiting in the queue?
What happens with movies, the
research shows the same thing.
Like if you're thinking about
what you're going to watch a
week from now, you order
really highbrow films.
But if you're going to watch
something tonight, you're
like, it's lowbrow stuff.
It's just let me escape.
Who can relate to what
I'm talking about?
Or another one, like you
download books on your Nook or
Kindle or your iPad or whatever
your reading device
is, and you're thinking about
things you want to
have there for later.
And you have biographies and
histories and science text and
non fiction and Nobel Prize
winning literature.
And you take that and you
get it all loaded up
to go on the airplane.
And you're like, yes.
I'm virtuous.
I have all this great stuff.
And you're in the airport.
What do you buy to read
on the plane?
AUDIENCE: "Twilight."
JUDITH WRIGHT: Yeah, "Twilight."
You buy whatever
you can grab to try to distract
yourself in the moment.
So this is what human
beings do.
And it's really interesting
because we think about this.
And the studies show this
over and over again.
Like, the movie thing, 77% of
people order the highbrow
thing now and then watch the
lowbrow thing tonight.
So that means most of
us are doing this.
Not that I'm not making
moral judgments.
I'm just trying to wake us up
to what our habits are like.
Because if you think about it,
if we really could design our
lives from scratch, which
we can at a level.
If we're really going to design
our lives, say, OK, how
do I want my life to be?
How do I want to live my days?
How do I want to
spend my time?
What is it that, if I could
really step back and be an
architect of my own life project
and put the pieces in
place and design that, I don't
think I would do this.
Like, OK, got to
design my life.
OK, I want to watch five
hours of TV a day.
And by the time I'm 60, I want
to make sure I've spent at
least nine years watching TV.
And I want to have at
least 12 hours of
screen time every day.
And that includes those
talking kitten videos.
And then I want to make sure
that my kids spend more time
watching TV by the time they
graduate than they've spent
going to school.
And, let's see, over shopping.
I want to over shop and be kind
of frenzied and max out
my credit cards.
And then I want to spend six
hours a week shopping, as
opposed to 40 minutes
a week with my kids.
And then I want to have so much
stuff that I have to rent
a storage container for stuff
that I never use.
And then let's see,
keep designing.
I'm missing something.
Oh, I got it.
I want to check my email 36
times an hour and then be
distracted for 15 minutes
afterwards trying to get my
focus back after every time.
And what am I missing?
Oh, I know.
I want to lower my IQ 10 points
by that compulsive
email checking and multitasking
so that I can dim
it a little bit.
And then I went to over snack
and eat a lot of empty
calories and get all
fat and bloated.
And then, wait, that's
not enough.
I got to get some-- oh.
And then I want to bite my
nails to a bloody pulp.
And, oh, and in any moment I
have just a moment just in
between things or any possible
down time, I want to grab my
smartphone and avoid people in
the elevator, walking on the
street, or even when I'm
at dinner with them.
And I want to check my
Facebook page in the
middle of the night.
And then I want to check it
right before I get up, right
as I'm getting up, before
I go to the bathroom.
And I'm still trying
to hold it in.
But I got to check my page.
And, let's see, I want to make
sure my kids sleep with a
BlackBerry instead
of a teddy bear.
And I want to make sure, let's
see, that I don't have enough
money for a vacation because I
spent $1,500 to $2,500 a year
on gourmet coffee
at Starbucks.
And I want to be distracted and
anxious and a little numb
and little buzzed and little
forgetful and a little zoned
out and look like this a
lot and answer people,
uh huh, I hear you.
You've put the kitten
in the dryer.
Uh huh, that's great.
I want to be like that rather
than conscious and engaged and
learning and growing and making
the best of my life.
So all this stuff are not the
elements of a designer life.
Yet--
I know I'm exaggerating
a tiny bit.
But, actually, I'm not.
Because everything I just told
you is statistically normal.
This is what people are doing.
This is the norm in our world.
We do watch five hours
of television a day.
We do watch nine years of
television by the time we're
60, et cetera.
All those things are
statistically normal.
But that's what's happening
in our world.
So that means that some of us
that are listening to this are
caught by some of
these things.
And it's fascinating because
there's two normals, if you
look at it.
There's normal of what
everybody's doing, which is
statistically normal.
There's another normal
of the normal
operating range of machinery.
And that's where machines
work best.
Those two normals are
very different.
And they are getting farther and
farther and farther apart
in our world.
And because of this, because of
what's normal, if somebody
doesn't think you're weird,
you're living really badly
because what's statistically
normal isn't in our normal
operating range.
It isn't where we
function best.
But that's kind of the norm of
how we are in our world.
And so how many of us say,
I just want to be normal?
That's not the best thing
for us at this point.
And I don't want you to get smug
that this doesn't apply
to you because that would be
a way of being addiction.
So I'm going to check because
we're all in this.
This is part of our human
nature, what's happening.
So part of it, like what's
the big deal?
And I think we're making
that point.
And I want to just go through
some of the stats and the cost
of mindlessness to really
understand how pervasive this
is and how that no matter how
much mindful work we do, how
this subtracts from that and
keeps us from having the juice
that every day could have.
So all these kind of mindless
activities that we so
naturally gravitate to, they
mute our consciousness.
They numb our feeling.
So they reduce our emotional
intelligence.
They reduce our social emotional
intelligence, which
affects our decision making
and our intimacy and our
genuineness and our contact with
ourselves and our ability
to really relate and
be creative.
It steals time.
Tremendous amounts of time are
eaten up in things that we're
not that aware of.
Oh, the intimacy, it diminishes
intimacy because
we're not there.
We're not fully present
with ourselves and
another human being.
And there was a recent study
at the University of Essex,
this was fascinating.
If you're out with someone and
you're trying to have a more
meaningful conversation, you're
sitting across the
table or next to someone, if
there's even a cell phone on a
table near you-- no one's
even talking on it.
Just having that cell phone on
the table as you're talking
reduces intimacy.
It lowers the trust and the
sense of connection and the
depth of the conversation.
And they think it's because
it's an indication that
there's other people.
It kind of represents there's
other people and you're not
just with the person, or it
could interrupt you in any
second so you don't relax
into the engagement.
But that in itself--
so the clues are there that are
disrupting intimacy, much
less when we're actually
on that when we're
at dinner with someone.
Multitasking.
And there's no such thing as
multitasking, even though most
of still try it.
We only pay attention to
one thing at a time.
And we're flipping back and
forth between things.
We're not as good at things
as we think we are.
But what happens when we
multitask or really
compulsively check our email--
the norm is 36 times an hour,
by the way.
That's statistically normal.
So what happens then is that
we lower our IQ 10 points,
which is the same as
smoking a joint.
I'm not recommending one or the
other necessarily, but to
kind of get what happens going
on in our noggin when
this is going on.
So what I say is it makes us
numb and dumber and fat and
fatter and all the other
implications that it has.
And it's a huge issue for us.
And it also costs
a lot of money.
Because if you think about it,
just think about it-- just a
handful of songs on iTunes and
a book or so on your reading
device or gourmet coffee,
you start to add
things up over time.
It really adds up.
And I've done these trainings
now with thousands of people
over the last 20 years.
The lowest amount we ever
heard people-- they do a
financial accounting to kind
of get the point for
themselves.
Oh my gosh, it's so sobering.
The lowest I've ever
seen anybody was
$3,000 for the year.
And this person was pretty
much a hermit.
He actually had avoidance
soft addiction.
The norm was $30,000
a year of just
kind of mindless spending.
And if you want to spend that,
that's totally fine.
But usually it's just money that
goes somewhere they were
not aware of, that's not going
towards what it is that we
really want.
So part of the deal with
this-- let me kind of
personalize this a bit.
And then we're going to play
with the neuroscience under it
and find out why this is.
Part of why I've studied human
potential for all these years
is because there was something
that I was looking at it in my
own life that I felt like there
was something more there
that I wasn't quite getting.
And I thought I was
living life well.
But something was
missing for me.
See if you can relate to some
of things I'm talking about.
I don't think your story
should be mine.
But just see what you can
see because I knew about
achievement.
I was always a great student.
I was valedictorian
of my class and
graduated summa cum laude.
And I was able to achieve.
And I was able to--
I rose to national prominence
in two different careers by
the time I was 28.
So I knew how to do well.
But at the same time I was
having career success, I was
overweight, overwrought,
overstressed.
There was--
even despite my success,
I was really unhappy.
I felt very empty.
And I felt like I was
sleepwalking through my life.
I was doing a lot of things,
but there was a
numbness that I had.
Something like life was
out there but I
wasn't touching it.
How many of you know what
I'm talking about?
That numb kind of sleepwalking
feeling?
How many of you are too numb
right now to raise your hand?
And I couldn't seem to
break what that was.
And I tried a lot of things.
So I lost weight.
I got a guy.
I worked harder.
I meditated more.
I prayed.
And it kind of helped.
But it didn't really
unlock it.
And then I partied a lot.
Where are my partiers?
I got to make sure we've
got a few of us.
They usually sit in the back.
So, hey, good.
There's a few of us.
So whatever it was, I kept
trying to try new things to
try to unlock this pattern.
And it wasn't working.
And I was just getting so
frustrated with my life
because I thought it
was a formula.
You do well, you try hard, you
have success, whatever.
It didn't work.
But what happened was that I
realized through some of the
work I was doing--
I started a demonstration
program, one of the first
programs in the country to set
up programs for students with
disabilities to be successful
on campus.
And I designed it and did
research and designed this
model program.
So I had these students--
paraplegic, they were
quadriplegic, or blind or deaf
or cerebral palsy, all
kinds of things they
were dealing with.
And then I also had a program
after that that I started at a
university for little children
that had developmental
disabilities and
their families.
And there was something that I
noticed because these people
were dealing with some
really tough stuff.
It wasn't easy to be doing
what they were doing.
And I realized that many of
these students and many of
these families with these tough
situations they were
dealing with were much
happier than I was.
And the contrast was
very stark for me.
And it was upsetting to me.
I was happy that they
were happy.
But I couldn't understand
what was going on.
And I discovered something
at that point.
And I had kind of an epiphany.
It didn't happen
in one moment.
But it kind of dawned on me
that there was something
really wrong with the formula
that I was going
about my life with.
Because I thought it was being
good, being a good girl, and
working hard and being perfect
and doing well at work and
having a perfect body, perfect
situation, perfect
circumstances.
And that wasn't it.
And it was very upsetting
to me to realize.
Because the people I was working
with didn't have
perfect circumstances or bodies
or minds or whatever,
yet there was a quality of
life that I didn't have.
And it really woke me up because
I realized, wait a
minute, it's not the formula
that I thought it was.
Because I work hard and then
try to have some recovery.
I would work hard and
then meditate.
I work hard, recovery.
Who's my work hard, recovery?
How may of you know that one?
You work hard and
then collapse,
work hard and collapse.
That formula wasn't
doing it for me.
And I finally woke up and I
realized that-- and it was
very upsetting to me because
it was so disturbing--
that it really wasn't
about that.
It was about consciousness.
It was about being mindful, not
just my mindful practices.
It was about being present in
the moment, feeling what I was
feeling, being able to express
those feelings, share those,
to be engaged fully in the
moment, in moment by moment
day to day kinds
of experiences.
It was about being fully alive
and being more real and being
willing to make mistakes and be
more vulnerable and allow--
I was so cool before.
You have never seen cool.
I was so cool.
And then I realized,
oh, my gosh.
This is not it.
It's about being warm.
That's much more important
on the other side.
And all those things started
to dawn on me.
And that was always being
modeled by the people that I
was working with.
There was a genuineness
in the moment.
They were present with
whatever struggles
that were going on.
Not everybody, but
many of them.
There was a realness.
It was so much different
in quality.
And I woke up and I realized
that I had learned to master
my eating by that point, but I
was still addicted to thinking
about food.
I hadn't shifted my relationship
inside.
I hadn't mastered my mood
addictions that had me feeling
certain ways and then I'd
compensate with other soft
addictions.
It wasn't about doing the right
stuff and achieving and
trying to be perfect
and being good.
That was not it.
And it was only when I realized
that some of these
students and some of these
families had a higher quality
of life than I did
that I really
started to examine this.
And it started me on this
journey, this deeper
commitment, that's taken me to
where I am today, where my
life has a tremendously
different
quality than it had before.
Because what I realized was that
I was hungry, but not for
all the snack food I was eating
and not for all the
activities I was buzzing
through my life.
I was hungry for something
much more.
I had deeper spiritual
hungers.
I had deep yearnings
on my heart.
There were things that
I really cared
about much more so.
And I realized that I was
misreading my yearning and
numbing it with my
soft addictions.
And I didn't know to call them
soft addictions at the time,
but I realized that
that was the case.
I started to turn toward what
it is I really yearn for.
And we're going to learn a
little bit more about that now
and learn a little more the
neuroscience behind this.
And that's when things
started to shift.
From the outside of my life it
looks pretty much the same,
but the inside is totally
different.
And I've given up
being perfect.
My life is not perfect.
That's not what it's about.
But it's a different kind
of journey for me now.
And I want to talk
about this more.
That's why I came up with the
term soft addiction because I
was also working with a lot of
high achieving people who
weren't making the progress in
all the quality of their life
that they really needed
or wanted.
And that this was the
same kind of thing
that I found in them.
So why is it this way?
Why is it so easy to fall?
And why are the statistical
norms the way they are?
Why is it so easy to fall into
all these habits and things
that we do that deprive us of
the quality of life and
connection and sense and
presence and consciousness?
But there is an answer to it.
And it's important for us to
understand it because it's
evolutionary.
Because what happens is
evolution should have weeded
all this stuff out if it
wasn't good for us.
But it can't because what
happens-- do you love this?
It's a little parody.
But what happens in evolution is
our circuits that we have,
we're always scanning for
threats or scanning for
opportunities.
That's what kept us alive
with early man.
Is there a saber-toothed
tiger coming?
Where's their food?
Those circuits that are always
scanning are what our survival
is based on.
But our soft addictions co-opt
those very circuits that we
can't get rid of because
they're part
of our being alive.
So co-ops those.
So it hijacks these systems
we have in our brain that
condition us to look for
food, for sex, to keep
us away from predators.
It's those same systems
that it takes.
So what happens is that we start
seeing threats as highly
salient and things that might
be novel or give us a little
dopamine burst as something
that's really salient for us.
So everything gets translated
into either food, sex,
circuits, or threats.
So what happens, we start
seeing-- and we're really
wired for the salience.
So what happens, we start seeing
salience in chocolate,
in, oh, let's see, yeah, for TV,
wet t-shirt contests start
looking really interesting to
us because it captures that
same circuit that's kept us
alive and kept us procreating
throughout life.
So part of why this is so
important for us to understand
is that we're hardwired to pay
attention to things that we
think are salient.
But we start seeing those
immediate consequences as
being more salient to us than
something long term.
So same thing, if we were like
an ancient man or woman and
there's a lion, we're going to
immediately deal with that and
stop building our hut.
So the longer term thing
gets pushed aside.
And that's pretty much
how we're wired.
And we need to be
aware of that.
So what happens is that soft
addictions capitalize on this
ready-made programming for us.
Now, what we need to do-- so the
longer term evolution of
us and our older brain and
our limbic system is
wired for the survival.
That's what gets captured
all the time.
And I'm going to teach you
about those neuroscience
circuits and those
in just a second.
But what need to do is use our
frontal lobe or prefrontal
cortex, which is the more
recently evolved part of our
brain, which is the more highly
developed part of our
brain that can counteract
that.
That's a part of our brain
that's interested in the long
term, in our dreams, in our
yearnings and possibilities
and what can happen and who can
we become and what can the
world be and what we can
invent and discover.
And all the things that create
all the beautiful things you
create here are from this part
of our brain as it overrides
some of those more
early signals.
And it's really important.
They've done some-- you may
have heard of the famous
marshmallow study.
So Walter Mischel did this
study-- some little
four-year-olds.
And they had this choice.
They sat at these little tables
and they had this
little marshmallow.
And they said, look, you can eat
the marshmallow right now.
But if you can wait a little
bit, you can have two
marshmallows.
Well, these four-year-olds,
it was so--
there's videos all
over of them.
You can watch them.
They're going crazy
with these.
They want to eat the
marshmallows so badly.
They're like licking it.
They're grabbing the middle of
it and trying to pretend they
didn't eat it.
And a lot of the kids just gulp
it, just gulp the one
marshmallow.
And other kids found
delaying tactics.
They sing.
They sit on their hands.
They spin around on
their chairs.
They look away.
They distract themselves and
wait and got the second
marshmallow.
This is a really important
experience for you to
understand because those
children that waited for the
two marshmallows, they studied
them longitudinally.
And by the time they were
adolescents and even later,
their social development was
way beyond the other kids.
Also their SAT scores were 210
points on average higher.
So that being able to delay
gratification, to look at what
a bigger reward later
is really critical.
It's a really important thing.
And that's part of what
we need to be able
to be looking at.
But what happens, if we're
easily distracted by the buzz
in our pocket or a chime of an
email or a smell of coffee or
whatever it is--
we're easily distracted.
All of sudden we forgot about
the two marshmallows of life
and we've gobbled the one and
we've not gotten the two.
So there's much better
gains for us if we
can sort this through.
So what happens with this
addictive process is anything
that triggers the possibility
of reward sends this amazing
dopamine squirt into
your brain.
And I'm going to have you play
with this in a moment.
I'm going to tell you a little
bit how this works.
And there's two different--
I'm going to skip ahead
a little bit, Kate.
There's two different circuits
in our brain that really help
us orient either to this
immediate pleasure or this
longer term kind of goal.
And I'm going to make this
distinction so I want you to
have the difference.
Because what happens, this
addictive process happens--
we have these hedonic
hot spots.
And actually what happens is
that there's one center in our
brain that wants and craves.
And there's another center
of our brain that yearns.
And it's different.
I'm going to have you have an
experience of this and then
I'm going to unpack this
a little bit for you.
So what happens is that we--
many of the neuroscientists
have found this.
We have things that we want.
But the wanting is very
different than liking something.
These two centers-- sometimes
they call it the wanting
center or the center of
excitement in our brain or the
seeking center.
And it's the one that gets
fueled by dopamine.
And it's really intrigued by
the possibility of reward.
But it's not the
reward itself.
And this is when we get
a little bit crazed.
We're kind of ah, ah,
ah and oh, oh, oh.
You get that little buzzed
kind of look.
On the other hand, we are
not wired for being
sated in that center.
There's another center
for being satisfied.
And they're different neural
circuits that do this.
The dopamine center
is our wanting.
It's what gets us kind of
motivated and high and gets us
to start engaging.
And the other center is
fueled by opioids.
And what are opioids?
What does that sound like?
Opium.
And what is opium known for?
It's kind of that bliss, that
satisfied pause, that bliss.
But we need both things.
But I'm going to give you an
experience of this and we're
going to unpack this
a little bit.
I'd like for you to
grab a buddy.
So if you could turn towards
somebody in the area.
Just find somebody.
Or if you're at the end of an
aisle and you don't have
somebody, you could make a
threesome if you want.
But the twosomes are best.
Does everybody have a buddy?
And if you don't have one maybe
raise your hand and we
can find somebody that isn't
connected to somebody.
Does everybody have a buddy?
All right, would you pick an
A and B with your buddy?
Pick an A and a B. A and
a B. All right, great.
Now, let me get you back.
I'm going to raise our
hand to get us back.
Come on back.
All right, A and B. Now, I want
you to have an experience
of the wanting center of your
brain, the one that gets
co-opted all the time the minute
you have a sense of a
possible reward or even thinking
about something you
might like or want
in the future.
And this is what gets triggered
when you smell that
burning coffee or hear
a little chime or
see that sexy girl.
This is all the stuff
that gets triggered.
So you're already
getting into it.
I'm talking, you're smiling.
So A and B, you're going
to talk at the
same time right now.
And what I want you
to do, I want you
to become want machines.
Like, how many of you have ever
seen a two-year-old in a
grocery store?
What are they like?
I mean, they want everything.
Like, what are they grabbing?
Everything.
They want everything.
They don't care.
They just enjoy the sensation
of wanting.
I mean, they're grabbing
tampons or Rolaids.
They don't care what it is.
They just want to want.
So right now I want the two of
you to talk on top of one
another just naming as many
things as you possibly can
think of that you might want.
You can say the same
thing over again.
I want her to shut up.
I want this to be over with.
I want coffee.
I want to go to do this.
I want a hot new car.
I want new clothes.
I want to discover
blah, blah, blah.
So two of you--
I'll cut you off in a second.
But just talk on top
of one another.
I want, I want, I want.
Wanta, wanta, wanta, wanta.
OK, let me get you back.
Let me get you back.
Good, come on back.
Now, just tell me, how do
you feel right now?
Where is your energy?
What's it like?
Chaotic?
Yeah, Yeah.
Can you feel?
Where's your energy?
Here, here, here?
Where is it?
It's kind of more
here, isn't it?
What do your eyes look like?
What did your buddy's
eyes look like?
[LAUGHTER]
JUDITH WRIGHT: This is a
neurotransmitter dopamine.
We get like this.
This is the part that gets
co-opted all the time.
You get high.
You get kind of buzzed.
You're kind of like, whoo.
It's like a party.
And how many of you even noticed
you had a buddy?
I mean, you kind of.
But it's not even relevant.
And you're just in this--
you're in your own zone
when this is going on.
And what happens, sometimes you
don't even remember what
you said or what you want.
You get forgetful.
You get buzzed.
You get kind of high.
So this is dopamine
in our system.
We need it because it's
what helps us get
motivated to take action.
But you never get sated
in that center.
It's not designed for that.
So I'm going to teach you about
yearnings for a moment
and then give you a little
more to work with.
Now go back to your buddy.
And you picked who's
A and who's B?
Take a deep breath.
Now, close your eyes for a
second because I'm going to
give you the language of
yearning and then we're going
to play with that and
see the difference.
So just close your eyes.
And I'll say some of these
universal yearnings of the
human heart that are related
to our satisfaction center.
I yearn to love and be loved.
I yearn to matter.
I yearn to make a difference.
I yearn to be seen,
to be heard, to
touch and be touched.
I yearn to the fulfil
my destiny.
I yearn to create and
to develop and to
learn and to grow.
I yearn to connect, to belong,
to be part of something
greater than myself.
Think about those yearnings.
See which ones feel
true to you.
Chances are all of them will.
But there might be one or two
that really touch your heart
or feel most important to you.
And take a deep breath.
And now if you'd open your eyes
in silence, just look at
your buddy.
And, A, I want you to start.
I just want you to very--
just a brief thing.
What I yearn to-- and just
fill in one thing.
I yearn to be loved or connect
or make a difference or
matter, whatever feels
true for you.
I yearn to-- just
say that phrase.
I yearn to.
All right, just return
to silence.
Return to silence.
Take it in.
And B, you share one.
I yearn to.
All right, good.
Thank you.
Now, come on back.
Let me get you back.
Now, tell me what your energy
feels like right now.
Where you do you
feel this now?
AUDIENCE: Calm.
JUDITH WRIGHT: It's calmer.
How many feel more calm,
more grounded now?
And it's not up here anymore.
Where is it?
Maybe more in your heart or
down somewhere grounded.
How do you feel about your
buddy right now?
How many of you can't believe
you kind of like this person
after saying that?
You kind of got to know them.
How many of you realized you
had a buddy in this part of
the exercise?
That happened.
There's a person there.
You're more there.
There's something there.
That's more of the opioids
and the oxytocin, the
neurotransmitters that you're
connecting with right now that
are helping you have this sense
of being sated, calmer.
It's a satisfied pause.
We need the balance of both
of these circuits.
But when they compete, the
wanting always wins, not the
satisfaction center, not
the yearning center.
So we have to really learn to
focus on the yearning center
so we can have the satisfaction
and the
consciousness and the
mindfulness that we really
need and want in our lives.
And let me tie this back
together with this whole thing
about soft addictions.
What is this about?
What is that?
See what happens, our soft
addictions are cravings.
They're wanting.
They're all fueled by those
evolutionary centers, the
dopamine squirts, and that fix
and that getting high and the
things that have kept us
alive all this time.
And we need them in order
to get motivated.
But underneath every single soft
addiction, that wanting,
that craving, is a
deeper yearning.
And the soft addiction is trying
to get our attention to
tell us what it is that
we really need.
If you really, really want a
big old bowl of ice cream,
what do you think could possibly
be the yearning
underneath that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JUDITH WRIGHT: We got
to talk after, OK.
If you want a big bowl of ice
cream, chances are you're
yearning for comfort or
maybe just literally
sweetness in your life.
If you just have to check your
email or your Facebook page
compulsively right this second,
what do you think the
yearning might be
underneath that?
AUDIENCE: Connection.
JUDITH WRIGHT: Connection.
Connection, belonging, being
important, being part of
something, knowing that you
exist, all of that's
what's going on.
So every soft addiction is
trying to tell you what it is
that you really need.
However, we just keep indulging
that with that
automatic dopamine high.
We never get the yearning met.
And it never brings us as
present and conscious and
fulfilling as we possibly
can have in our lives.
It doesn't bring us the results
of all those things we
talked about earlier
in the talk.
So what I want you
to think about--
I'm going to give you
an assignment.
And we can talk about it more
and you can ask some questions
and we can be with
this together.
I want you to look at what
is it that you do
have cravings for.
What do you want?
What are the wantings?
Like, that little guy going
wanna, wanna, wanna.
Nothing wrong with wanting.
Many people need to have
that activated.
It helps us engage more
fully in life.
But what's the deeper yearning
underneath that?
What is it trying to tell you?
Because then, if we really
want to design our lives,
unlike the design your life
examples I gave you earlier,
the normal design, if you really
want to design your
life, you design it to meet
those yearnings, where every
moment you yearn to connect, to
contribute, to matter, to
love and be loved, to touch
and be touched, to make a
difference, to be present,
to learn, to grow.
Every single moment of your life
can be guided by those
deeper yearnings and bring a
high quality to every single
second of your life.
And if you start designing
your life to meet that,
everything starts shifting and
you have their motivation to
go after things in life.
But you know how to get the
satisfaction with that.
And what happens then?
You have more consciousness,
more time, more money, more
productivity, more intimacy,
more meaning, more
fulfillment, better stress
responses, all the things--
your IQ is functioning
the way it should be.
Your thinking is clearer.
Your critical thinking
is better.
All these tremendous results
come from being mindful about
our mindlessness and learning
what our system is
trying to tell us.
So your assignment is to think
about some of your yearnings
and what can you put into your
life more fully than you
already are that would meet
those and also stay aware of
what is that you want, what do
you crave, and to be willing
to tell what it is you really
yearn for underneath and add
more things to your life that
meet those yearnings.
And what happens when you do
that, the more you meet those
yearnings, your soft addictions
start to melt away.
You don't have to worry so much
about white knuckling
through things because the
need is getting met.
So the same desire isn't
there in the same way.
So you'll still use all the
beautiful things you use.
You'll use your technology.
You'll have beautiful food.
You'll have all the things
that you might
be attracted to.
But you use it differently in
a way that fulfills you and
makes you even a greater
gift in the world.
So that's the big stuff
underneath what
this yearning is.
And in fact, we've done more
research since this.
This is going to be coming
out in our new book.
It's going to be out the
beginning of the year.
And found out that yearning is
actually the beginning of a
whole cycle of what people
go through that really
transformed their lives to
live spectacular lives.
Every hero you've ever had has
based their life on yearning.
And then there's several other
things we found after that we
need to do-- engage
in things that
really meet those yearnings.
So we all have them.
And I'd like to encourage you to
go and meet them some more
because you'll be an
even greater gift
than you already are.
And if we can support you in any
way, I'd love to do that
and I'd love to hear any
questions that you have in a
few moments.
And also before you leave, if
you'd like, we've got some
assists and supports for you,
some downloadable products.
And we have a training you
can go to complementary,
all kinds of things.
But if you're interested we
have little cards for you.
You can give us a business card
before you leave today.
And I'd love to.
It's part of my yearning to make
a bigger difference and
to have more friends on the
planet who are living the way
that we're talking
about today.
So I just want to thank you.
Thank you for having this time
together and spending this
time meeting yearnings.
So thank you.
And thanks, Rachel, for
making this happen.
Thank you.
RACHEL: Are there
any questions?
Questions, questions.
JUDITH WRIGHT: Yeah, go ahead.
We use consciousness things.
We set a timer or whenever
you have a moment.
We look inside just
what am I feeling?
I'm feeling anxious.
I'm feeling whatever.
And so it's more
of a presence.
So let me know what you find.
And things that really help
us with our stress--
under stress we're so prone
to soft addictions.
The executive centers of our
brain shrivel under stress.
Our habit formation brain
gets bigger and
blooms during that time.
So what we really need are
things that actually help us
reduce stress.
But it's not all the mindless
stuff we do.
It's talking with a friend.
It's listening to music.
It's reading something
beautiful.
It's exercising.
It's being in nature.
It's all the things that
actually reduce our stress and
bring our brain functions
back.
So any other questions
or thoughts
that you want to share?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'd like to know
a bit more about
the avoidance ones.
JUDITH WRIGHT: Yeah.
Yeah, if you look at it,
avoidances have meaning.
There's a yearning behind
those as well.
Oftentimes, procrastination,
there's a yearning for
comfort, a yearning for
security, a yearning for
protection.
One of the reasons people
procrastinate is that they
know the minute they start
working on something they're
going to get driven so they
limit the amount of time that
they're going to work on it.
That's not everybody.
But some people do that.
So they're trying to protect
themselves from getting lost
in some way.
So for each person the yearning
can be a little different.
But there is a different
yearning.
How many of you are
procrastinators?
I have been one and am one.
And it's really interesting
because it's hard to see
what's the positive, what's the
yearning underneath that.
But often time it's a way that
we're trying to take care of
ourselves rather than adding
things to our life
that would calm us.
Because procrastination,
we're usually scared.
We may not have the information
we need.
We may need more help.
It may feel like a big cliff
we've got to get over.
And we need more help.
We need more resources.
We need more strategy.
And it's a clue for us to
prepare and take care of
ourselves rather than
just a push it away.
Does that work for you?
Thank you.
Yeah.
OK, great.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering, what
was it about the people
you learned from, the people who
you were taking care of--
disabled--
that enabled them
to avoid these?
Did they not have the time?
JUDITH WRIGHT: You know, it's
interesting because I'm not
sure exactly how to describe
what their
motivation was or whatever.
But there was something about
they were so present in the
moment doing what they could
to learn and grow and take
advantage of the situations
that they had,
that it wasn't about--
they couldn't be under the
illusion that someday
it'll all be OK.
Someday it'll all be perfect.
So they weren't so--
there was a being present
and a genuineness.
They couldn't hide
their mistakes.
Like one guy I worked with,
he was deaf and he
had cerebral palsy.
And he came to me one day
and he was laughing.
I said, what are you
laughing about?
And he said, I was just at
the-- he used sign there.
I was just in the cafeteria
and I was eating my lunch.
You know, I've got CP.
So the food's flying
all over the place.
And it's all over me.
And I said, what's so
funny about that?
And he said, all the
kids were laughing.
And I said, what's so
funny about that?
And he said, I can't
hear them.
So wow, there was just this--
I'm not saying that everybody
was like that.
But there was this just dealing
with what life had in
the moment, vulnerably, present
with feelings, with
the upset, the frustration,
the anger, the joy of any
small success that
was an experience
that I wasn't having.
And the families that were
dealing with these little kids
with these disabilities, the
ones that went through the
tough work of mourning the loss
of the child they thought
they were going to have so they
could love the one they
had, there was an appreciation
and acceptance of what was,
what is, that created a lot
more satisfaction and
happiness in those families
even after the so-called
tragedy and then before.
So there's this facing a reality
and being genuine in
the moment that was a quality
that I hadn't been having in
my own life.
RACHEL: Thank you very much.
JUDITH WRIGHT: Great.
Thanks, Rachel.
Thanks all of you.
Thank you.
Thanks.